while bringing some color into what
would normally be a grim situation
silver state pediatric invited local
artists to come and display their
artwork on the walls of their facility
now normally a place where children are
treated for an array of medical needs so
this really makes walking this hallway
just a much more
enjoyable experience for the kids for
the children who have to stay in house
they get to enjoy their imaginative
murals right there in their bedrooms as
well
we got about 12 artists to donate their
time and talent
and we kind of let them do what they
wanted to do
galaxy theme through one of our common
areas that's
beautiful as sun and moon all of the
artists came up with their own concepts
as you heard there and did this free
of charge for the children if anyone is
interested in displaying the art through
other medical facilities you can reach
out to the group through social media
we will have that contact information up
for you on our website at 8newsnow.com
great job